hier geht's weiter mit Alice Weidel der
Vorsitzenden der Fraktion der AFD
als Olaf Scholz und Friedrich Merz exakt
gleich klingen wie peinlich ist das
eigentlich mal merkt dass Friedrich Merz
unbedingt Bundeskanzler werden will der
redet schon wie Olaf Scholz aber nun ja
doch ist so noch zwei Wochen aber dann
ist die wohl schlechteste Regierung in
der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland ein volles Jahr im Amt bei
ihnen im Kanzleramt mögen dann die
Korken knallen für die Bürger gibt es
dagegen nichts zu feiern 12 Monate Ampel
das sind 12 Monate mutwillige Zerstörung
unserer Wirtschaft und unseres
Wohlstandes 12 Monate Gängelung bevor
Mundung und Schröpfen der Bürger zwölf
Monate Politik eine Regierung die
Einschränkungen Predigt während sie
selbst aus den Vollen schöpft eine
Politik die die Regierungsapparat um
mehr als 10000 Stellen aufbläht das muss
man sich mal vorstellen Deutschland ist
er dafür bekannt zu wenig Beamten zu
haben und sich für
400.000 Euro einen persönlichen
leitfotografen für den Vizekanzler habe
gönnt eine Politik die sich mitten in
der Krise mit einem gigantischen Ausbau
des Kanzleramts ein Monument des eigenen
größenwahnsätzen will viermal so groß
wie das Weiße Haus neuer Hubschrauber
Landeplatz zweite kanzlerwohnung mit 250
Quadratmetern für Kanzler Olaf und 400
neue Büroräume inklusive kosten fast 800
Millionen Euro
dekadenta geht es kaum
Täuschungen und Unwahrheiten sind die
Währung der Politik dieser Regierung
einer Politik die die auf Illusionen
Wählerbetrug und Hofberichterstattung
des öffentlichen Rundfunks gebaut ist
das wohl größte und teuerste
Lügengebäude ist die sogenannte
Energiewende sie wollen dieses
wahnsinnsexperiment am offenen Herzen
unserer Volkswirtschaft bis zum bitteren
Ende durchziehen gegen alle Gesetze der
Natur und Physik ein Industrieland mit
Gelegenheit Strom aus Sonne und Wind
betreiben dabei aus Kernkraft Kohle und
Erdöl gleichzeitig aussteigen und sich
als Backup für die fake-power aus diesen
sogenannten erneuerbaren Energien allein
auf teures Flüssiggas setzen diese
Illusion ist die Lebenslüge der
Energiewende sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren
wir haben keinen Stromproblem mit dieser
dreisten Falschbehauptung hat der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister die Bürger
noch Mitte Juli hinters Licht geführt
ich weiß nicht was da passiert ist
vielleicht hat der Habeck zu lange in
der Sonne gelegen anstatt zu arbeiten
weil ansonsten wären ja dieser
schwachsinnige Satz überhaupt nicht
rausgerutscht denn wir haben einen
Stromproblem Millionen Bürger erfahren
dieser Tage von ihren Stromversorger
dass sich der
kilowattstunden-preis deutlich mehr als
verdoppelt Tendenz steigend das
Bundesamt für Bevölkerungsschutz und
Katastrophenhilfe rechnet im Winter mit
Strom Abschaltung in ganz Deutschland
eine Zumutung für die Menschen pures
Gift für die Wirtschaft und ein
Armutszeugnis für ein Industrieland
die Sprengung der nordstream-leitung war
ein nie dagewesener Angriff auf unsere
lebensnotwendige Infrastruktur
offenkundig von einem anderen Staat
Reaktion dieser Bundesregierung
dröhnendes schweigen und warum tun sie
eigentlich nichts dafür dass Russland
Erdgas durch die intakte Leitung von
nordstream 2 liefert um dem Pleite zu
Nami in der deutschen Wirtschaft zu
verhindern wer wenn irgendwann
herauskommen sollte dass der Kanzler
einen
unterschriftsreifen Vertrag auf dem
Tisch hatte um Erdgaslieferung über
nordstream 2 nach Deutschland
sicherzustellen um die Not abzumildern
wehe wenn das irgendwann mal
herauskommen sollte ihre Politik
zerstört Deutschland
Rezession und Inflation
Pullman den produktiven Mittelstand das
Rückgrat unserer Wirtschaft und treiben
die bürgerliche Mittelschicht in die
Verarmung die Ursache für beides ist
nicht der Ukraine Krieg das ist eine
jämmerliche Ausrede die Ursachen sind
die von Merkel und der CDU begonnene und
die von ihnen ins Absurde
gesteigerte grüne Energiepolitik die
Energie systematisch knapp und teuer
macht die repressive corona-politik die
falsche hochsteuerpolitik die
Sanktionspolitik gegen Russland und die
Verschuldungspolitik der EU die den Euro
zu einer sterbenden Wohlstands
vernichtenden
inflationswährung gemacht hat das ist
das Ergebnis ihrer Politik
das EU-Verbot des verbrennermotors
wird den Automobilstandort Deutschland
zerstören und unsere Industrie die
Weltmarktführerschaft kosten aber sie
jubeln darüber
die ideeindustrialisierung Deutschlands
ist schon in vollem Gange die
Großkonzerne gehen ins Ausland die
Kleinbetriebe gehen pleite
und mit ihnen
gehen Hunderttausende von Arbeitsplätze
verloren
die Erzählung vom reichen Land ist ein
Lügenmärchen in Deutschland ist nur der
Fiskus reich und diese Leute dort und
macht die Arbeiten der Bevölkerung arm
darum geht es doch hier den flationen
lässt real Einkommen Ersparnisse und
Renten dahinschmelzen was die Leute sich
ein Leben lang hart der arbeitet haben
ist bei diesen Inflationsraten nach drei
bis vier Jahren nur noch die Hälfte wert
und lassen Sie mal weitere Jahre ins
Land ziehen was da passiert aber sie
denken gar nicht daran die Gier der
Steuerstaat ist so zügeln um die
Menschen zu entlasten wer seine
Lebensleistung seinen Kindern vererben
will wird gnadenlos abkassiert von wegen
mit der FDP GWS keine Steuererhöhung und
zu allem Überfluss
verhöhnen sie die Bürger auch noch mit
teuren Steuergeld finanzierten
einfältigen Werbekampagnen dümlicher
besser
und penetranter Einmischung in die
private Lebensgestaltung die
aufdringliche corona-entfärbung eines
Lauterbach ist eine doppelte Frechheit
sie ist nicht nur miserabel gemacht sie
verbreitet auch vorsätzlich längst
widerlegte Falschbehauptung
die
MDM
RNA Impfung schützt nicht vor der
Übertragung des Virus das ist
nachgewiesen darauf war sie nie angelegt
das hat die kaisermanagerin Janine small
bereits vor Wochen in einer Anhörung des
EU-Parlaments zugegeben aber Karl
Lauterbach der Pharma Lobbyist im Gewand
des
Gesundheitsministers klammert sich
weiter an die impflüge auf deren
Grundlage Millionen Menschen unter Druck
gesetzt und ungeimpfte unerträglich
diffamiert wurden das totalitäre
Experiment ihrer corona-politik die
unsere Gesellschaft schwer beschädigt
hat muss ein Ende haben und
aufgearbeitet werden
dann musst du auch die zweifelhafte
Rolle vieler Medien auf den Tisch die
nicht nur in der corona-krise als
Kontrolleure der mächtigen versagt haben
die Ausfälle eines öffentlich
rechtlichen fernsehproleten der im
Zusammenhang mit dem Virus Kinder als
Ratten und Pest über Träger bezeichnete
sind ein bitterer Tiefpunkt finanziert
über Zwangsgebühren wie erbärmlich und
dann noch dieses hirnrissige gendere
einfach nur noch bekloppt was hier
abgeliefert werden darum fordern wir
seit Jahren die Abschaffung der GEZ
Zwangsgebühren es ist unerträglich
Medien
die schließlich als hofschranken der
Regierung betätigen statt frische
kritische Fragen zu stellen sind Teil
des Problems einer maßlosen
corona-politik genauso wie das
irrationalen klimawands und der völlig
aus dem Ruder gelaufenen
Migrationspolitik der offenen Grenzen
deutschland hat in diesem Jahr schon
mehr Migranten aufgenommen als auf dem
Höhepunkt der asylkrise 2015/16 die
Kommunen sind hoffnungslos überlastet
und sie nehmen den Kontrollverlust nicht
nur hin sie heizen die Migranten Sturm
auch noch an sie schließen
Sonderabkommen zum Import von 10.000 in
Afghanen sie verteilen Millionen an
Schleuser darunter auch die Organisation
von dem Partner von Frau Göring-Eckardt
das muss man sich mal vorstellen und Sie
schaffen mit dem Umbau
das hartz-iv-systems und Bürgergeld
einen mächtigen
migrationsmagneten der asylzuwanderer
mit den höchsten Sozialleistungen aller
EU-Staaten lockt wer ist nach
Deutschland schafft muss faktisch nicht
mehr gehen und hat über kurz oder lang
Anspruch auf volle Sozialleistung und
allen Bürgerinnen das hat mit einer
verantwortungsvollen
einwanderungs- und Asylpolitik wirklich
gar nichts mehr zu tun
die deutschen zahlen die höchsten
Steuern und Abgaben aller
Industrieländer am bekommen dafür ein
dysfunktionalen Staat verwahrloste bei
kanalisierte Innenstädte verfallende
Infrastruktur heruntergekommene Schulen
und ein parasitäres Sozialsystem und
ausufernde Ausländerkriminalität das ist
das Ergebnis ihrer Politik und sie
verteilen überall die Steuergelder hin
während die eigenen Landsleute nach der
Flutkatastrophe im Ahrtal auch nach
einem Jahr noch auf dem Trümmern ihrer
Existenz sitzen wie beschämend helfen
sie endlich diesen Menschen den Flut
Opfern und hören Sie auf die Bürger
auszunehmen anzulügen und für dumm zu
verkaufen
alles Weidel afd-fraktion
[Applaus]